[Applaudissements]
amis téléspectateurs bonjour et
bienvenue sur le plateau dès maintenant
l'émission qui revient avec plaisir et
avec vous sur l'actualité politique de
la semaine vous connaissez le principe
hashtag et maintenant si vous souhaitez
réagir dans ce numéro des invités de
très très très très haut niveau vous les
connaissez déjà ils nous font le plaisir
et l'honneur de revenir n voir Fabrice
Dalmeida bonjour bonjour Steve historien
vice-président de l'université Panthéon
Assas votre dernier livre s'intitule
histoire mondiale des riches c'est à
retrouver chez plomb une nouvelle recrue
aujourd'hui bonjour Dina Cohen vous êtes
journaliste politique au Figaro merci
d'être avec nous Sophie de Ravinelle
revient bonjour absolument bonjour
journaliste politique au Figaro
également et Christophe aguitton bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sociologue et militant
altermondialiste merci d'être avec nous
c'est une émission forcé un peu
particulière aujourd'hui pour moi
présentateur mais aussi pour vous invité
j'imagine pour vous aussi derrière votre
écran après le massacre commis par les
terroristes islamistes du Hamas en
Israël où l'on compte encore les morts
on a forcément forcément moins envie de
sourire que d'habitude on aurait
beaucoup de mal à traiter d'autres
sujets que celui-ci on a donc décidé de
revenir sur cette attaque barbare telle
qu'elle est vécu à l'international et
telle qu'elle est vécu ici chez nous en
France mais d'abord la sidération la
sidération face à l'ampleur de l'attaque
commise par les terroristes ce jeudi le
chef de l'État a reçu les chefs de parti
à l'Élysée pour une réunion consacrée au
sujet dans la foulée Emmanuel Macron a
pris la parole pour affirmer son soutien
à l'État hébreu écoutez-le Israël a
connu samedi l'attaque terroriste la
plus tragique de son
histoire le Hamas a exécuté un plan qui
par son ampleur sa barbarie son bilan
humain n'a pas de
précédent tout un pays a été surpris à
l'aube par des tirs et une invasion
aussi soudaine que
sanguinaire des centaines de nourrissons
d'enfants de femmes d'hommes ont été
pourchassés enlevés assassinés pris en
otage des massacres de
kibuts des villages entiers décimés une
haine meurtrière aveugle un déchaînement
de cruauté absolue on va revenir bien
évidemment sur les propos du président
mais déjà peut-être Fabrice pourquoi
c'était important pour Emmanuel Macron
de prendre la parle
maintenant et sous ce format il y avait
un peu moins d'une semaine qui s'était
écoulé il y avait déjà une très très
très forte émotion il y avait des débuts
de polémique entre force politiques
entre communauté je pense que c'était
fondamental de rappeler à un moment que
notre angle il est français et le chef
de l'État je trouve dans son discours
pour une unité nationale a rempli sa
fonction il fallait dire oui on regarde
oui on on a des relations oui on a des
amitiés mais mais nous sommes français
donc nous ne sommes pas totalement
directement dans le conflit quoique
quoique puisque on se rend compte depuis
qu'il y a 17 français qui sont Tage et
13 qui ont été tués donc qui ont été
impliqués directement dans les
événements donc c'était important qu'il
ait une parole qui qui nous rappelle à
nous-même comme collectivité nationale
et qui en même temps ben disent que dans
ce dans ce massacre il y a eu il y a eu
des morts français des morts nationaux
et c'est pas anodin même si je trouve
que on en parle pas assez h Dina il
s'adressait à qui le président
effectivement à nous Français citoyens
français oui je pense qu'il s'adressait
à toute la nation et qu'en effet il y
avait un un vrai besoin de de clarifier
les choses et de porter aussi un message
d'apaisement il a parlé notamment de la
communauté juive aussi de la communauté
musulmane et je pense que c ces deux
messages en effet étai étaient très
importants parce que après une une
semaine de conflit on a vu comment et ça
on en reparlera plus tard mais on a vu
comment ça pouvait rapidement s'importer
dans le pays et je pense qu'on avait des
communautés qui avaient besoin aussi de
d'entendre ce genre de message et puis
de clarifier aussi la position de la
France par rapport à Israël une position
typiquement française et équilibrée on a
vu qu'il a été extrêmement clair dans sa
manière de nommer les choses par rapport
à aux massacres qui se sont déroulés
initiés par le ramas il a aussi commencé
à à initier le fait que Isra Israël
avait le droit de se défendre ce qui est
très important à dire tout en préservant
la vie des civils ce qui prépare aussi
pour la suite parce qu'on sait que dans
les jours à venir beaucoup de choses
vont se passer que l'évolution aussi de
de la riposte d'Israël va
potentiellement faire évoluer l'opinion
publique et donc je pense que c'était
important de poser les bases d'une d'une
réponse légitime de la part d'Israël
mais dans la dans le respect d'un
certain nombre de règles et notamment au
fait de toucher la vie des civils sopil
CTA un message de clarifie
de la part du président oui un message
de clarification même si on aurait sans
doute souhaité qu'il y ait encore plus
de clarification et notamment pour ce
que souigne Dina Cohen
concernant la la la le côé la dimension
juste de la Rost qui doit intervenir
forte et juste absolument et cette
question forte et juste et puis il parle
d'attaque ciblé et et là effectivement
on est devant quelque
chose extrêmement compliqué évidemment
et qui finalement met en
valeur disons la la la la sidération
aussi des forces politiques françaises
et de l'État français face à ce qui
s'est passé et à une forme non pas de
dénis mais de sidération parce qu'ils
n'ont jamais mesuré ce qui était il on
le voit bien ils n'ont pas mesuré ce qui
ce qui s'est passé effectivement ce
samedi matin à 7h ce qui cette cette
invasion c'est massacre ces actes
terroristes et et du coup il y a non
seulement de la part de la France hein
mais de toute la diplomatie européenne
parce que Emmanuel Macron ne parle pas
qu'au français il parle aussi à tous ses
homologues européens et finalement comme
si cette chape de plomb qui avait été
posé sur la Palestine sur la bande de
Gaza sur cet énorme problème avait été
posé et et personne n'imaginait qu'elle
allait se soulever et du coup il y avait
aussi chez Emmanuel Macron il y a eu
chez Emmanuel Macron euh et bien un
manque parce que justement comme si la
diplomatie française n'avait pas été
préparée à cela et donc n'était pas en
mesure d'apporter une réponse complète à
la situation Christophe il est important
auss pour le chef de l'État de rappeler
on l'a entendu ce soutien à l'État
d'Israël au peuple israélien en pareille
situation moi j'ai trouvé la la première
partie de son intervention juste sur
l'émotion hein sur l'ampleur des
massacres sur la condamnation sans
équivoque et sans embage de ces
massacres bien évidemment sur le fait
qu'en effet des des des français sont
morts ù ont été pris en otage sur le
fait qu'il fallait pas importer ce
conflit chez nous et en effet respecter
d'une certaine façon une une certaine
identité nationale au-delà évidemment
des divergences normales dans un pays
démocratique la deuxième partie par
contre pour moi ne relève pas du tout du
même niveau hein et je pense que là il y
a vraiment beaucoup de choses à dire sur
l'affaire ferme mais ou ou ferme mais
juste for et juste donc sur le les
civils on a l'impression jeudi soir que
Emmanuel Macron n'avait pas de télévis
pas de radio et ne lisait pas les
journaux jeudi soir on savait déjà que
1400 civils palestiniens étaient morts
1400 c'estàd le même nombre que
d'Israélien hein dès jeudi soir ça il le
savait depuis on sait qu'Israël demande
maintenant aux Palestiniens du nord de
Gaza de passer au sud ce qui pourrait en
laisser penser qu' une grande opération
de nettoyage ethnique pourrait avoir
lieu ce serait le pire hein c'estàdire
en fait une expulsion des Gazaouis de
Gaza hein ça c'est pas une affaire qui
est complètement hors de champ quand on
voit ce qui est le gouvernement mon
Netto écoutez franchement quand on
regarde quand on regarde ce qu'on très
fort sur ce qui estoslavie c'est pas des
déplacement de population c'était des
massacres faut faire
attention une partie des
ministres netaniaah se fait on fait
campagne là-dessus compris compris sur
les Arabes israéliens je parle même pas
des S jordaniers de Gaza donc ce danger
n'est pas complètement exclu mais
troisème chose qui moi m'a marqué c'est
le fait que sur ce qui est de la voix de
la France et là je rej ce que disait
Sophie dravinel tout de suite on était
inaudible ces dernières années c'est
Dominique de Villepin qui le rappelait
récemment dans une de ses interviews la
France a oublié complètement qu'il y
avait des Palestiniens c'est un peu
comme si les accords d'Abraham ces
accords entre
Israël 2020 et cetera avait réglé tous
les problèmes et ça c'est un vrai
problème et et là on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure je pense qu'il
y a une voix spécifique pour la France
et pour l' qui n' pas encore été porté
jusqu'ù ya le soutien de la France à
Israël vous parli Christophe alors
qu'une guerre longue et sans doute très
coûteuse en en vie humaine s'annonce
Emmanuel Macron parle donc de la
nécessité pour Israël d'apporter une
réponse forte et juste aux attaques
islamistes quelques jours plusutôt le
porte-parole du gouvernement n'était pas
tellement plus précis écoutez Olivier
Israël a vécu son 11 septembre ensuite
Israël est un ami est un pays que nous
que nous soutenons toujours pour moi il
me revient pas de commenter ce matin ce
la manière dont Israël euh décidera de
d'engager une
ripost le chef de l'ONU Antonio gouterz
se dit bouleversé par l'annonce du siège
de Gaza nous sommes évidemment sous
mandat de l'ONU et nous suivons le les
recommandations du Conseil de sécurité
en en tout en la matière la diplomatie
française ne se distingue pas de la la
diplomatie onusienne en la matière alors
on parlait des choses qu'il y avait dans
ce discours d'Emmanuel Macron il y a un
mot qu'on n pas retrouvé c'est
effectivement le mot cesser le feu
Fabrice c'est difficile là dans le
contexte où il y a des protagonistes qui
sont dans une action de de guerre
j'allais dire très très chaude très
proche c'est difficile de parler de
cesser le feu c'est l'horizon et c'est
vrai
que d'une certaine manière ce qui a été
dit ici et et peut-être la je sais pas
s'il y a une responsabilité française ou
européenne mais on n pas réussi à
maintenir le lien et au fond la claque
que tout le monde prend c'est que on
avait l'illusion euh qui était une
illusion que avec le temps
éventuellement avec l'assouplissement
des mesures restrictives sur la
Palestine que les Israéliens prenaient
au goutte à goutte qu' a une
responsabilité française dans ce qui se
déroule là-bas dans non ce que je veux
dire c'est que on pensait que ça pouvait
se régler avec le temps avec
éventuellement un développement
économique qui aurait recommencé à se
faire en donnant un peu d'aide
économique à Gaza et et à la sjordanie
en en en alimentant au fond avec l'idée
que vous savez cette cette vieille idée
qu'on a en France malgré tout qui est
déjà présente chez Benjamin Constant qui
était présente aussi en partie chez
Colbert c'est le doux commerce au fond
on va réussir à à civiliser les gens par
les par l'économie ça n'a pas marché et
et on s'est pris ça assez violemment en
retour et ce qu'il y a de vrai quand
même c'est que il y a plus il y a eu
plusieurs étapes dans lesquelles la
réaction française a peut-être pas été
non plus très très active mais il y a eu
quand même 2012 il y a eu 2014 il y a eu
les manifestations euh euh au aux
frontières entre les deux états de la
part des des gazawit et il y a pas eu de
voilà il y a pas eu il y a pas eu voilà
il y a pas eu de réaction et c'est ce
qui fait que il y a eu ce calme qui
était en fait tactique euh du Hamas nous
qui a endormi et c'est pour ça que la
claque est d'autant plus forte que euh
on pensait que le Hamas avait changé en
fait ils ont rappelé que leur chares de
88 était euh toujours en activité
radication d'Israël euh Sophie jusqu'ù
le souti de la France peut aller donc
pas de mot de cesser le feu sans doute
des opérations et des combats très dures
à venir la la position de la France et
d'Emmanuel Macron est-elle tenable et si
oui pendant combien de temps en fait la
position de la France et d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est celle des pays occidentaux
c'est celle du droit internationale
c'est celle voilà c'est on ce ce ce
droit obéi à des règles alors évidemment
la diplomatie internationale est faite
d'hypocrisie et nous sommes en guerre
enfin la Israël et la Palestine sont en
guerre c'est ce sont des mots qu'il faut
employer il y a au bord de laabîme et
donc dans ce cadre là ce sont c'est le
cadre normal des des disons de d'État en
guerre enfin je sais le terme normal
n'est pas n'est pas juste mais c'est
c'est compliqué de savoir ce que la
diplomatie française peut faire seule
évidemment que la France a une voix
singulière dans ce conflit évidemment
que l'histoire française est singulière
là-bas et ici en Europe mais il est vrai
que il va a avoir à un moment évidemment
dans l'attente de ce qui effectivement
va se passer sur le terrain la question
de savoir est-ce qu'on peut il va y
avoir un débat sur le terrorisme d'État
il va y avoir un débat sur la nature des
armes on a tous le conflit syrien en
tête et les armes qui ont été utilisées
là-bas qu'est-ce qui va pouvoir
qu'est-ce que la France pourra faire
dans cette mesure on comprend
parfaitement la gène là encore de notre
diplomatie et des représentants au
gouvernement Christophe sur la
diplomatie française et peut-être le
rappel d'Emmanuel Macron de la position
traditionnelle de la France deux états
pour deux peuples mais sur le droit
international c'est peut-être une nuance
avec ce que vous venez de dire je pense
qu'il y a des choses qui sont claires en
partic Israël a le droit de se défendre
hein et tout État attaqué a le droit de
se défendre ça ça fait partie des règles
absolument il y a la proportionnalité
mais il y a des des choses qui sont
faites et qui ne relèvent pas du droit
international prenez par exemple le
blocus l'idée de couper l'eau L'eau hein
c'estàd que les gens ne peuvent pas boir
hein bon l'électricité et et bref tout
ce qui est le blocus et le siège de Gaza
qui date de 2007 qui est un blocus
israélien bloc je par des blocus total
qu'on mis en place du SI siège si vous
voulez hein si c'est plus clair pour
tout le monde mais ça c'est et l'ONU le
répète hein ça n'est pas quelque chose
qui est reconnu le droit international
notorise pas le siège pour des
populations civiles ça n'est pas
autorisé donc et c'est déjà fait et moi
ce qui m'inquiète c'est le fait que on a
été en effet aveugle je suis
complètement d'accord avec fabricema
là-dessus sur la période précédente mais
on se prépare à des des illusions
futures si on ne commence pas à discuter
de ce que dit par exemple Benjamin
netanahou quand il dit que Hamas égale
daesh il fait une erreur à mon avis qui
est pas selement une erreur conceptuelle
et historique mais qui est aussi une
erreur pour le futur daesh était une
organisation qui voulait une espèce de
diihade mondial essayer d'organiser un
Califa sur la totalité de la planète et
était capable à cause de ça de faire
tous les massacres qu'on a connu mais
aussi de faire qu'on peut pas comparer
le le Hamas et daesh non mais bien
évidemment parce que eux daesh a été
capable de faire venir des milliers de
Français de Bel mag de igour et d'autres
qui sont venus se battre pour unih
mondial le Hamas une organisation
nationaliste qu'on reste vraiment en
France à l'ésée on s'inquiète de
l'ortation du
conflit Paro dans uneeation du conflit
en France et la formule consacrée
Emmanuel Macron a appelé ce jeudi à
l'Union sacré écoutez je sais je le
disais la peur de nos compatriotes de
confession juiv que cette résurgence
là-bas de la violence antisémite soit le
prétexte ici de parolle d'injure d'actes
qui les viseraiit et je mesure aussi
l'inquiétude de nos compatriotes de
confession musulmanes que les amalgames
l'emportent sur la raison nous
combattons et combattrons toujours pour
que nul sur notre sol n'est peur
discours d'union sacrée je vais vous
montrer ce sondage élable dans lequel on
peut on peut voir que 85 % des Français
se disent inquiets de la situation dans
la région trois Français sur quatre
pense que ce conflit risque de s'élargir
à d'autres pays voisins et deux sur
trois que ce conflit représente un
risque de tension en France c'est un peu
un conflit français avec des guillemets
aussi Dina ça a été un peu nationalisé
dès le début avec les réactions
politiques qui l'ont commmenter je pense
que ça a été apporté assez vite en
France avec d'une part le rassemblement
national qui a immédiatement fait un
parallèle entre le ramas et le
terrorisme islamiste qui pouvait y avoir
en France d'autre part la France
insoumise qui a eu imp positionnement
ambig aussi évidemment en reparler donc
c'est vrai je pense que ça s'est
nationalisé assez rapidement euh et en
effet mais mais il y a un risque
d'importation du conflit aujourd'hui oui
je et je pense qu'il commence déjà à
s'importer tout doucement Gérald armanin
recensait déjà une centaine d'actes
antisémite en l'espace d'une semaine
c'est quand même beaucoup on on peut pas
dire le contraire et la sécurité a été
renforcée dans tous les lieux de culte
juifs et je pense que c'était aussi très
important qu'Emmanuel Macron et un mot à
l'égard de la communauté musulmane qui
elle aussi a des craintes euh et
malheureusement euh les jours à venir
vont probablement être de plus en plus
compliqués aussi pour une partie de de
la communauté juive en France et on
parlait tout à l'heure du du soutien de
la France à Israël et jusqu'où il peut
aller je pense que au fur et à mesure
que des images potentiellement terribles
vont nous arriver de de Gaza notamment
avec les opérations qui se préparent
l'opinion publique va potentiellement
glisser aussi petit à petit euh et il y
a de quoi craindre aussi une résurgence
des acte antisémite à l'égard de la
communauté juive motivé par les images
qui vont nous arriver deux Français sur
tris considèrent qu' que ce que ce
conflit représente un risque de tension
en France c'est un chiffre énorme
Fabrice non oui mais qui est j'allais
dire qui reflète l'expérience qu'on a
des des conflit précédent
euh en gros à partir des années 60 70
l'extrême gauche a vraiment importé le
conflit palestinien comme un conflit de
justice mondiale et à partir de ce
moment-là on a eu en France les les les
premiers
mouvements où la politique se mêlait
dans une critique d'Israël du judaïsme
du sionisme et puis le le vrai moment je
pense où où on a vécu quand même des des
tension très forte c'est à partir de
2000 où on avait une croissance
systématique des actes antisémites
directement lié à ce qui se passait en
Israël et en Palestine donc il y a cette
expérience tout le monde le voit tout le
monde le sait il y a des intellect qui
ont pris la parole pour pour le dire
pour le dénoncer il y a eu des on a vu
les mobilisations des forces de police
on a vu la protection nécessaire des
lieux pas seulement de culte mais aussi
de de réunion de du monde juif donc oui
il y a ça après quand on dit importation
du conflit c'est un mot qui est quand
même très très fort on l'utilise comme
ça c'est différent de dire il y a de la
polémique entre des groupes d'avis
différents et importation du conflit
comme ça c'est fait pour parfois chez
nous je pense à aux Kurdes et à la tur
Turquie qui faisait des attentats et des
contreattentats et des exécutions sur
notre territoire je pense à un certain
nombre de massacre terroristes qui a eu
comme en 2012 quand Mohamed Mera se rend
dans l'école au zaratora et tue
délibérément des enfants juifs ça pour
moi c'est là c'est on est dans le
conflit la vraie guerre après c'est
autre chose de dire que et c'est une
partie qui est déjà engagée de de dire
qu'il y a la polémique entre les amis de
la Palestine les amis d'Israël voilà ch
manifestation étit organisée en France
en réaction aux événements du Proche
Orient le ministère de l'Intérieur a
annoncé l'interdiction de toutes les
manifestations proalestinienne il a
envoyé un télégramme au préfet pour
queils agissent en ce sens Gérald
armanin a expliqué la position du
Gouvernement devant les journalistes
écoutez-le c'est pour la cause
palestinienne c'est une cause absolument
respectable la France d'ailleurs a
toujours considéré et je considère qu'il
faut deux états un israélien et un
palestinien mais si c'est une
manifestation de soutien au Hamas ou de
soutien à l'action de qu'on fait une
partie euh évidemment des palestiniens
contre Israël c'est non donc depuis
dimanche nous avons interdit au cas par
cas mais toute jusqu'à présent toutes
les manifestations qui soutenaient
l'Intifada qui appelait la haine des
Juifs interdiction de toutes les
manifestations proalestinennes qu'est-ce
que ça vous évoque Sophie c'est vraiment
démocratique écoutez moi c'est je je je
trouve que dans l'absolu on ne peut pas
empêcher dans notre état des
manifestations ça c'est un un un
préambule
euh on a vu à à quel
point le risque pendant même dans
d'autres crises d'une autre nature je
fais une analogie et pas une comparaison
il y avait eu au moment des gilets
jaunes et de d'autres crises sociales
des tentatives de restreindre comme ça
les libertés publiques bon ça c'est un
point et c'est une base démocratique
ensuite là dans ce cas précis si il y
avait autant de manifestant pour la
liberté au Tibet et si ça ne VI enfin
voilà il faut comparer avec la question
de ces manifestations c'est le contenu
ce qu'il y a il y a aussi là une
hypocrisie c'est-à-dire est-ce que ce
sont des manifestations de défense du
peuple palestinien qui a absolument le
droit et qui doit être défendu dans son
droit à exister ou est-ce que c'est une
des manifestations qui visent à à à à
dire qu'Israël n'a pas le droit aussi
dire qu'il faut faire du cas par cas
mais alors et c'est compliqué de faire
du cas par cas c'est quasiment
impossible et c'est là où on se he mais
bien sûr mais on se heurte au réel
question c'est que si c'est un déversoir
de la haine contre Israël et contre le
droit des Juifs à vivre en Palestine ENF
je veux dire c'est c'est c'est
totalement compliqué et donc on est à la
fois sur un principe de droit et un
principe de réalité et les deux qui se
heurent aujourd'hui évidemment en France
Christophe sur ces interdictions non je
pense que elles ne sont pas justifié
surtout elles ne le seront pas dans le
futur parce que ce dont il s'agit c'est
pas en effet une importation du conflit
je suis aussi d'accord avec Fabrice
d'Almeida là-dessus comme a pu le faire
daesh qui a fait des les attentats est
terribles on les connaît tous hein sur
Charlie le batlan et cetera c'est pas de
ça dont il s'agit c'est un conflit
interne à la Palestine et à Israël
puisqueon efface à deux logiques
politiques qui s'affrontent et qu'on
connaît bien mais ce qu'on va avoir nous
en France c'est autre chose c'est une
réfraction qui tient au fait qu'on a la
plus forte communauté juive d'Europe et
la plus forte communauté Arab
mususulmane d'Europe donc inévitablement
dans ces deux communautés je suis
d'accord avec le fait que le le
président de la République là-dessus a
eu des mots qui étaient juste moi qui
m'ont pas posé problème du tout bon mais
maintenant si on veut que les choses se
passent bien il faut que les gens
puissent s'exprimer et et s'exprimer pas
du tout en défense du du Hamas ou des
attentats c'est pas ça oui mais mais à
partir d'aujourd'hui vous voyez bien là
on a déjà 1400 morts dans les
territoires à gazaoup d'ut vont arver
que le déplacement d'1000 s'il a lieu de
Gazaoui va être quelque chose de
terrible nul si des manifestations ce
samedi ou dimanche ou lundi ou mardi de
la semaine prochaine ont lieu qu'est-ce
qu'on fait qu'est-ce que fait l'état qu'
les
autoris là je pense qu'il faut les
autoriser par autorise toutes les
manifestations qui auront lieu sur
l'affire de Gaza mais ce ne seront pas
des manifestations en défense du Hamas
évidemment non parce que ceux qui
appellent il y en a eu certaines en
défense prenez par exemple hier soir
avanth soir pardon il y a eu une
manifestation à Paris jeudi soir hein
bon qui a eu lieu et qui était interdite
3000 personnes sur la place de la
République il y a pas eu d'incident il y
a pas eu de drapeau du
Hamas non je sais mais la défense de
Gaza c'est ça qui va s'exprimer et et
donc ça si on l'interdit on aura des
actes antisémites parce que les gens qui
ne pourront pas manifester pourront
déverser leur haine sur une mosquée sur
une mosquée ou sur une synagogue ou
autre chose je pense que le fait de
laisser la société respirer donc
s'exprimer c'est la base de la
démocratie V dire c'est que
l'interdiction risque de mettre lement
évidemment je suis pas je comprends le
principe de défense de la liberté
d'expression mais on a deux principes
contradictoires deux principes
contradictoires il y a celui de dignité
peut-être que là il serait pas en cause
et puis ensuite le principe de sécurité
et la note d'intelligence de
renseignement qui a été remise au
ministre laisse entendre quand même que
un il peut y avoir l'infiltration et
deux il peut y avoir un truc beaucoup
plus gênant qui est ce qu'on appelle de
l'apologie du terrorisme et ça ça pose
quand même un problème après une
interdiction systématique c'est pas la
question ce que dit Gérard Darmanin oui
non mais c'est c'est une suspension
pourquoi on peut pas dire d'un côté on
veut pas qu'il y ait une incandescence
du pays et moi je crois pas du tout
qu'il y a un rapport et et de l'autre
côté laisser se monter et se mobiliser
de plus en plus les les petits intérêts
particuliers les uns contre les autres
je le dis comme ça parce que pour moi ce
sont des opinions qui ne sont pas la
France voilà est-ce qu'il fallait
laisser le CRIF appel une manifestation
Mo
oui ils ont fait une manifestation je
pense pas qu'il fassent de l'Apologie
pour le terrorisme je pense pas qu'il
mett en place en publ ils ont pu
s'exprimer et c'est très bien et c'est
très bien Darmanin je pense que dans
l'optique de Darmanin d'abord c'est pas
une interdiction définitive mais mais
elle a un fondement sécuritaire et je
pense que là on n'est pas complètement
dans dans de l'absurde et puis aprèss
après la question non je je finis juste
Sophie je sais que c'est pas bien de
couper les femmes sur les plateaux mais
je trouve pas la parole je finis juste
ma phrase je finis juste ma phrase je
finis juste ma phrase donc juste pour
dire que c'est pas une interdiction
définitive c'est une suspension je pense
que dans ce moment du conflit justement
il y a peut-être besoin de raison garder
pour éviter que ça que ça s'accentue
justement trop Sophie oui pardon mais
désolé de vous avoir interrompu c'est de
ma faute absolument mais pois sur ce
plate ah n'estce pas c'est c'est Marc
merci non ce que je voulais dire c'est
que réagir sur la question d'interdir
pour des raisons de sécurité et c'est
pour cela que je faisais une analogie
avec les gilets jaunes pour essayer de
dégager du cadre extrêmement inflammable
qui est celui dans lequel nous nous
situons aujourd'hui avec voilà ce
conflit
importé quasi en France potentiellement
c'est que en fait avec c'est la le
risque du glissement c'est-à-dire que à
partir du moment où on dit pour des
raisons de sécurité on va empêcher les
les droits fondamentaux de s'exprimer on
peut tout laisser et effectivement
évidemment que c'est temporaire
évidemment que mais on a vu chez Gérald
armanin quand même déjà des signaux un
peu inquiétant de volonté de restreindre
les libertés publiques et en même temps
on est
complètement gêné et et voir choqué et
voir bouleversé par des cris de haine si
jamais effectivement il s'expriment et
des apologies du terrorisme dans ce type
de manifestation et donc là je pense
qu'effectivement il faut laisser à
chaque peut-être préfet la des
tentatives d'expression parce
qu'effectivement très justement s'il n'y
a pas d'expression populaire on sait
très bien aussi comment les choses
peuvent se passer on avait la même chose
enfin c'est la question du carnaval
autrefis dans nos sociétés
traditionnelles même si évidemment il y
a pas de comparaison mais il faut
pouvoir effectivement dire les choses
condamnation en tout cas presque unanime
de l'attaque terroriste du hamass dans
la classe politique presque car chez les
insoumis on refuse de parler d'actes
terroristes écoutez quel est la
définition vous donnez du Hamas
aujourd'hui c'est une la branche armée
qui aujourd'hui est responsable de CRIM
de guerre voilà et don et c'est
largement documenté vous
pourrez mais j'ai répondu sur terroriste
en fait terrorist ou pas j'ai répondu
sur
terroriste et bien j'ai répondu sur
terroriste vous vous si si vous vous
contenterez de ma
de ma réponse sur cette question un
double langage non je n'ai pas de double
langage monsieur et je ne vous permets
pas de des pudeurs de gazelle la France
insoumise entre guillemets lespur de
gazelle oui je pense que là la France
insoumise montre un visage qui était
redouté et auquel on pouvait s'attendre
mais dans une dans une ampleur assez
impressionnante euh et c'est vrai que le
les ambiguïés dès le départ du premier
communiqué de de la France insoumise ont
été
absolument impressionnantes on on a on a
entendu manuel bonpard qui par la suite
le coordinateur de la France insoumise a
un petit peu tempéré la position mais on
voit que c'est ce n'est pas que la que
les cadres de la France insoumise on
voit aussi que dans les députés dans les
je pense notamment à des députés comme
Louis Boyard ou arcilia souet qui ont eu
des propos encore plus problématiques
ceuxlà n'ont pas spécialement fait
marche arrière et on voit bien que là on
entre dans quelque chose alors peut-être
qu'il y a une part de conviction
peut-être probablement qu'il y a aussi
une part rel électoraliste parce qu'on
sait que ça touche à une partie de la
population dont le vote peut s'orienter
notamment vers Jean-Luc Mélenchon donc
on voit qu'ils sont extrêmement prudent
mais une prudence qui finalement dévis
sur sur le fait de de ne pas savoir
nommer des choses qui sont pourtant
vraiment juste devant eux et qui sont
qui ne peuvent pas être nommés autrement
je vais vous lire le communiqué d'ù vous
parliez ce communiqué publié par la
France insoumise le 7 octobre
l'offensive armée des forces
palestiniennes menées par le Hamas
intervient dans un contexte
d'intensification de la politique
d'occupation israélienne à Gaza en
sisjordanie et à Jérusalem m nous
déplorons les morts Israéliens et
Palestiniens nos pensées vont à toutes
les victimes Christophe ce communiqué
c'est une erreur ou c'est révélateur de
quelque chose de plus profond pour moi
c'est avant tout une erreur pour la
comprendre il faut revenir à ce qui
s'est passé il y a presque un an hein
quand Jean-Luc Mélenchon a décidé de
purger la direction de la France
insoumise pour en exclure ceux qui
avaient le plus d'expérience politique
je pense à Alexis Corbier je pense à
Clémentine Autin je pense à François
Ruffin qui tous ont eu des paroles je
trouve moi dit sur le conflit actuel qui
n'ont rien à voir avec ce communiqué
donc c'est une direction politique
faible qui a fait un communiqué à
l'évidence ambigu voire pire he mauvais
aucun doute là-dessus mais je pense que
la divergence entre la France insoumise
et le reste de la nupes est plus
compliqué que ce que l'on veut bien
croire pour le dire en deux mots on a
d'un côté le Parti socialiste qui
historiquement a toujours été
proalestinien en tout cas depuis des
décennies hein maintenant et de l'autre
côté les communistes les vers Europe
Écologie Les ver et la fr France
insoumis qui ont des positions assez
similaires qui consistent évidemment à à
rejeter des massacres de civils comme
ceux qui ont eu lieu par le Hamas le 7
octobre mais aussi de comprendre que le
peuple palestinien nécessitait d'être
défendu d'avoir un état et cetera et eux
ont plutôt insisté là-dessus c'est des
positions assez similaires c'est ce qu'
a exprimé manuel bonpard quand il s'est
exprimé plus tard hein parce que je
crois que c'était
mercredi qu'il a fait une interview qui
n'était pas du tout de même teneur que
le communiqué initial on on a on a
entendu encore on a entendu ces mots de
de Mathilde Panou qui ne parle pas donc
d'attaque terroriste qu'est-ce qu'il
craignent pourquoi ce mot est un
épouvantail pour eux Sophie vous
connaissez bien vous vous êtes
spécialiste vous suivez la gauche
française alors en fait ce mot
terroriste n'est pas du tout unodin en
tout cas chez eux parce que il pour lui
doit être comme me l'explique un des de
ceux qui a participé à la rédaction des
programmes insoumis j'en parlais avec
lui hier parce que je je je je je publie
ce weekend donc une page sur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et son isolement dans le
Figaro je fais de la pub mais il
m'expliquait en fait le mot terroriste
pour eux est un mot atlantiste donc à
relier à l'otant et qui sépare l'Axe du
Bien et l'axe du mal évidemment et ça
n'est pas du tout leur engagement ils ne
sont pas sur cette ligne là et donc il
revendiqueent le fait que l'ONU
n'utilise pas ce terme là non plus ils
sont dans une dans une approche qui se
veut
justement beaucoup plus lié au droit
international sauf qu'en fait il ne
mesure pas justification non non mais
alors j'y crois parce que théoriquement
ils ne sont que dans la théorie et en
fait c'est ça qui les fait qui qui qui
fait leur perte entre guillemets c'est
qu'ils sont restés sur une analyse
théorique intellectuelle froide quand il
aurait fallu comme François Ruffin
savoir répondre à l'émotion et là moi ce
que je pense c'est qu'il y a quelque
chose qui dépasse ce conflit qui habite
effectivement Jean-Luc Mélenchon la
conviction qu'il sera de nouveau
candidat en 2027 et à cause de cela une
volonté
d'affrontement une volonté de fraction
une volonté de brutalité parce que il se
moque de la classe politico-médiatique
et finalement ne veut répondre qu'à ses
électeurs ce que j'ai compris Fabrice
que nous dit notre ami Sophie c'est que
c'est électoraliste cette position non
elle l' a dit deux choses et je suis
assez d'accord la première chose qu'elle
dit c'est que c'est ça a une dimension
doctrinale ça a une dimension j'allais
dire identitaire et et qui est en
cohérence avec une partie de l'extrême
gauche depuis les années 70 c'est en gr
pourquoi l'idée que on est
anticapitaliste on est
anti-occidentaliste on est
anticolonialiste et le conflit qui
symbolise un peu tout ça c'est Israël
contre la Palestine et donc on est du
côté palestinien parce que les
Palestiniens se sont les colonisés ce
sont les opprimés ce sont les Orientaux
et ce sont en quelque sorte les
représentants du prolétariat
international et d'une certaine manière
c'est les mêmes motif qu'invoquaient des
gens comme les Brigades rouges ou comme
la rotte armée fractionne pour s'unir
avec ceux qui allaient faire les
attentats notamment à munque en 1972 je
là-dessus il y a une une continuité
historique qui est forte après il y a la
deuxième chose que vous évoquez mais je
suis pas sûr que ce soit elle la plus la
plus forte dans dans le moment qu'on a
vécu la deuxème chose c'est
effectivement la stratégie du
fractionnement de de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
et ou la stratégie qu'on pourrait
appeler de rupture si on voulait faire
un hommage à Jacques vergess qui
incarnait assez bien ce motif là
antiisraélien pour pas dire antisémite
et et et et prolétarien tiermondiste
quoi voilà donc il y a cette deuxième
optique de de la stratégie de rupture
mais mais je suis pas sûr que que en
l'espèce ce soit ça moi je pense que
c'est un peu ce que vous avez dit au
début c'est un peu le leur cR du cœur
intellectuel quoi enfin
c'est la question c'est si je peux me
permettre vous laisse la parole je te
laisse la parole Dinard mais c'est c'est
que en fait les communistes portent
exactement le même projet queeux sauf
qu'ils ont réagi totalement
différemment dans la mémoire communiste
juste dans la mémoire communiste et dans
la pratique de la CGT et cetera il y a
toutes les organisations internationales
du mouvement travailliste donc il se
retrouve à aller régulièrement faire les
jeux à poell faire du sport avec les
travaillistes israéliens donc c'est pas
tout à fait la
mêmeme is palestinien avec Christian
piquet en particulier qui est un ancien
de la LCR et qui est aujourd'hui le là
on arrive sur des sur des micro détails
j'aimerais vous montrer une réaction
parce que faut quand même que les gens
puissent mais vous êtes des
spécialistesuton puiss qu Mme
ABS
lesisionmee compliqué pour tout leonde à
l'intérieur de la franceoumise il y a
quelques petites voies quand même qui se
sont élevé pour se démarquer de la ligne
officielle c'est le cas notamment du
député Alexis Corbier et de François
Ruffin le député insomie de la Somme dit
la chose suivante à nos confrères du
monde je je condamne sans réserve les
actes du Hamas c'est une organisation
fanatique terroriste qui a toujours été
l'adversaire des progressistes prche
Orient hostile à tout compromis de de
paix qui veut la fin de l'État d'Israël
pourquoi lui et pas les autres je parle
de François Ruffin non je je pense que
c'est vrai qu'il y a dans l'histoire de
l'extrême gauche la Palestine est un
combat un peu symbolique hein bon il y
avait le Chili dans les années 73 les
années 70 mais la Palestine a toujours
été là bon ça c'est vrai mais il y a
dans dans les débats de la gauche et de
l'extrême gauche une notion qui était
très importante et qui l' toujours
aujourd'hui c'est que la fin ne justifie
pas les moyens puisque les moyens
transforme la fin c'est un débat
classique de morale philosophique et et
et de débat de de de Science Po est bien
connu et et pour ces raisons-là je pense
que toute une partie de l'extrême gauche
et de la gauche actuelle à juste titre
condamne les actions du Hamas comme des
action terroristes parce que c'est
exactement ce qu'elles sont et qui
discréditent le les combats du peuple
palestinien donc ça c'est pour ça qu'il
l'a exprimé bon pour ce qui est des
autres moi je pense que c'est Sophie
dravinel qui a raison je pense que
derrière Jean-Luc Mélenchon est dans une
stratégie qui vise à se débarrasser dans
la France insoumise de ceux qui
pourraient lui faire de l'ombre en
particulier ceux que vous avez cité
Corbière
Ruffin
il a raison il a raison et pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon le plus important c'est de se
débarrasser de ceux qui lui font de
l'omre dans la France insoumise et
d'essayer de casser la nuupess ce en
quoi il est aidé par son compère Roussel
du Parti communiste mais c'est ça sa
stratégie parce qu'il veut être candidat
à la présidentielle et ne veut pas être
soumis à une espèce de confrontation que
ce soit sous forme de primaire ou de
débat au sein de la nuupes ou d'autres
pourra lui dire B tu peut-être pas mieux
pour nous représenter et et donc pour ça
il il tape sur tout ce qu'il peut bon un
des des communiqués les plus incroyables
de Jean-Luc mé c'est de la petite
histoire il accuse Europe Écologie Les
Verts d'avoir été avec le gouvernement
français qui est aussi faux en faveur du
soutien de de l'arrêt des soutiens
humanitaires au Palestiniens ce qui
n'est ni la position du gouvernement
français ni évidemment la position
d'Europe écologi ver donc on a quelque
chose qui qui une bataille de bulldozer
et je pense que ce que dit Sophie
dravinal est la bonne explication c'est
toujours la bonne explication quand on
écoute Sophie dans la nesse beaucoup se
son élevé dans la nupes pour et bien
pour dire leur incompréhension face à la
position des insoumis écoute
le député Jérôme Gedge j'ai été
abassourdi dégoûté effrayé de voir que
dans ce
moment-là on pouvait avoir une
relativisation une
explication chercher peut-être des
circonstances explicatives à
l'intervention des terroristes Dina
cette affaire çaattend encore un peu
plus les relations à l'intérieur de
l'anupes bah c'est pas comme si tout
allait bien en plus déjà avant ça on
était quand même je pense que Sophie le
direa encore mieux que moi on était dans
une période un été qui a été très
difficile une rentrée qui a été très
difficile aussi et c'est vrai que une
fois de plus on se retrouve dans dans un
moment où notamment entre le Parti
socialiste et la France insoumise il y a
des divergences de fond quand même sur
des sujets fondamentaux parce qu'on
parle d'un sujet fondamental notamment
pour la France et pour l'Internationale
et on on arrive sur des divergences qui
sont difficilement dépassables dans la
mesure où la France insoumise maintient
ses positions et j'entendais aussi
Fabien Roussel vendredi matin qui
lui-même soulignait ses dissensions
alors évidemment Fabien Rousel ça fait
un moment que de de toute façon lui joue
aussi sa partition et s'éloigne le chef
du parti communiste exactement et
s'éloigne de plus en plus de laanupesse
et là il soulignait le fait que en
l'état ça semble impossible de de de
continuer de travailler avec la France
insoumise mais pourtant il n'y a pas
rupture non il n a pas r on discutait il
y a en fin de semaine avec un un une
figure éminente ancienne du gouvernement
socialiste qui disait mais enfin que
font les députés insoumis a encore
participer ou insoumis ou d'ailleurs de
laanupes à des groupes de travail avec
Mathilde Panau et de fait il y a une
incompréhension je pense que ce que tous
veulent au sein de laanups c'est
l'étranglement du clan Mélenchon et
maintenir malgré tout l'unité parce
qu'ils savent que c'est indispensable
pour 2027 assiste--on à une nouvelle
étape de la normalisation du
rassemblement national en tout cas cette
semaine Marine Le Pen a tenté de
s'afficher comme le soutien numéro 1
d'Israël contre le Hamas écoutez là ce C
octobre 2023 nous avons assisté à ce que
nous pensions ne plus jamais revoir dans
l'histoire de l'humanité des pogrommes
des programmes sur la terre même
d'Israël au cours desqueles on a tué des
femmes des enfants des hommes uniquement
parce qu'ils étaient juifs ces attaques
sont un crime contre les humains mais
aussi un crime contre la paix contre cet
extraordinaire et LAN processus qui ces
derniers mois semblait progresser
rapprochant Israël et les nations arabe
nous Français nous avons revécu avec
effroid les horreurs du Bataclan ou les
tueries d'enfants de Mohamed Mera le RN
est un parti normal Dina en tout cas il
essaie de l'être et je pense que les
mots sont très forts de oui les mots
sont très forts il y a non seulement le
discours de Marine Le Pen mais je
voudrais aussi souligner le fait que
Jordan Bardella a occupé les plateaux
toute la semaine sur le sujet il était
dès lundi matin sur BFM TV il me semble
et à l'écouter il se faisait presque
presque le le principal défenseur
bouclier de de la communauté juive et je
pense qu'avec cet événement tragique le
rassemblement national est en train ou
du moins essaye de faire sauter l'un des
derniers verrous à savoir son rapport à
la communauté juive à la question juive
et et c'est vrai que le fait que le
rassemblement national ait pu se rendre
à la marche du CRIF notamment ce sont
des faits révélateurs après je voudrais
aussi souligner député Ren à la marche
voilà exactement et c'est pour ça que je
voudrais souligner aussi le le fait que
le rassemblement national le fait de
manière relativement intelligente parce
que par exemple à la marche ni Marine Le
Pen ni Jordan Bardella n'étent présent
je ne pense pas que ce soit le
signe que qu'il y avait une hostilité à
leur à leur égard mais c'est plutôt que
Marine Le Pen sait qu'elle est par le
passé elle n'a pas forcément été la
bienvenue et ils choisissent des des
images ils y vont petit à petit
finalement à baborui et je pense que
c'est assez intelligent de leur part et
de l'autre côté assez inquiétant parce
que parce qu'on voit de de de de vraies
étapes qui sont en train d'être
franchies et quand on entend Jordan
Bardella défenseur affirmer de la
communauté juive alors que Marine Le Pen
na quand même jamais renié l'héritage de
son père c'est important de le souligner
Fabrice tout est oublié il y a une
recomposition du RN depuis quelques
années là on se souvient que Marine Le
Pen par rapport à son père avait
installé la question laïque dans
l'espace public donc il y a une forme de
continuité et puis ce qui est pas béni
pour eux c'est quand même le le parti
qui depuis le rég
déteste l'islam l'islamisme et tout ce
qui s'en rapproche donc au fond là ils
ont une illustration de ce qu'il de ce
qu'ils affirment depuis quand même pas
mal de temps ils profit de la situation
pour se laver les mains se blanchir par
rapport au au passé par rapport à
Jean-Marie Le Pen et ils sont aidés par
les oumis oui bon mais je veux dire y a
a il y a du prétexte mais il y a du fond
aussi c'estàdire que je pense que il y a
une tendance de fond chez Marine Le Pen
à ça à être antiterroriste à être anti
islamiste et à vouloir une France laïque
dans laquelle au fond la communauté
juive peut avoir une place c'est pas
pour elle ça c'est c'est cohérent
j'allais dire depuis des années qu'on
regarde son comportement qu'on regarde
son entourage après c'est vrai que la
situation permet de faire des des
analogies avec la société française et
en quelque sorte d'aller taper dans le
cortexte de la population pour dire nous
on serait plus sérieux mais ce qu' a ce
qu'il y a quand même d'intéressant dans
cette situation c'est qu'on se rend
compte que le parti d'extrême droite
israélien qui était censé être le parti
de la sûreté et de la sécurité qui
depuis 20 ans a fait toutes les
stratégies de rupture et cetera a failli
ils ont failli de qui vous parlez ben je
parle de nataniaou ce qu'il a fait il a
failli donc est-ce que cette extrême
droite française sera mieux placé pour
défendre le peuple français on peut se
poser des questions certains vous diront
que le Liquid n'est pas forcément en
extrême Dr j'aimerais vous faire
entendre dire all le peutre cette
intervention du député des Français de
l'étranger meilleur Habib qui est
justement proche de benamine netaniaou
et bien il estime que le RN oui a changé
écoutez-le non je ne crois pas que le RN
soit de loin le seul rempart mais le RN
aujourd'hui pour moi à la différence de
certains est rentré dans le dans le camp
républicain ils ont condamné de façon
claire et nette je ne pense pas que
Marine Le Pen soit antisémite je vous le
dis de la façon la plus claire qu' soit
elle n'est pas antisémite son père l'été
peut-être qu'autour il y a encore
quelques personnes qui le sont et ça
c'est c'est une c'est une on ne peut pas
l'accuser de choses elle ils ont été
irreprochaes par rapport à leur réaction
Sophie le parti a changé le
rassemblement national a changé et bien
écoutez on on va voir un petit peu
comment ça va se passer au moment P à
son âme mais il n'est pas encore du
décès de Jean-Marie Le Pen parce que
évidemment tout va ressortir à ce
moment-là sur l'histoire de cette
formation politique sur ses origines sur
ses racines et c'est là où si je peux me
permettre mais si josais j'apporterai
une toute petite nuance parce qu'il y a
une fascination pour la civilisation
arabo-musulmane aussi à l'extrême droite
en France et qui se transforme en
antisionisme dans certains cas c'est
vrai et il y a c'est vrai autour de
Marine Le Pen effectivement avec des
gens comme Frédéric chation c'est
absolument et du coup ça
provoque des des des des choses qui vont
forcément à un moment se voir et cet
antiionisme cet
antisémitisme j'allais dire dans leur
ADN il est aujourd'hui politiquement
effacé par effectivement un comportement
qui est parfaitement adapté à la
situation on peut même dire qu'elle est
assez brillante dans sa façon avec
Jordan Bardella donc ce n'est pas que ma
conviction c'est est-ce que c'est la
communication où vraiment là on est on a
une position
idéologique rassemblementtion c'est de
la politique pure ils savent très bien
qu' qu'il faut apparaître comme les
rempars d'une communauté dans un moment
en France particulièrement conflictuel
on l'a dit tout à l'heure sur la
question des manifestations où en fait
il y a eu un afflux d'immigration ces
dernières années qui a totalement en
partie participer à même si ce n'est pas
la seule cause évidemment parce qu'on
est sur des causes économiques on est
sur des causes structurelles de la
société françaises mais à des
antagonismes extrêmement forts et que
ces antagonismes aujourd'hui arrivent à
des points qui ne sont pas des points de
rupture mais qui sont des points
potentiellement d'exlosion et évidemment
que Marine Le Pen dans ce cadre làà met
toutes ses armes de côté parce que nous
avons tous en tête 2027 le rassemblement
national qui veut montrer sa différence
par rapport au aux autres partis sur le
sujet et une différence notamment avec
la France insoumise écoutez marine le
je ne veux pas faire l'union nationale
avec la France insiste qui considère que
le Hamas n'est pas un mouvement
terroriste je ne veux pas faire l'union
nationale avec la France insoumise et
ses alliés avec des gens qui minimisent
les attentats terroristes qu' subit
Israël qui soutiennent le Hamas qui déni
son caractère terroriste je ne le veux
pas Christophe elle nous dit moi je suis
fréquentable mais pas les insoumis oui
oui elle veut déplacer le cordon
sanitaire he bon et derrière c'est sûr
que l'extrême droite française est
européenne he ce n'est pas qu'en France
à cible aujourd'hui l'immigration et
l'islam les deux étant très proche pour
eux hein en tout cas puisque l'essentiel
de l'immigration est d'origine musulmane
et c'est ça qu'ils veulent faire comme
disons point marquant de leur
orientation politique dans les années
qui viennent comme ils le font déjà
depuis quelques années on l'a vu sur les
migrants en Méditerranée ou sur d'autres
sujets bon ça c'est certain ça n'est pas
les seuls hein j'avais été moi très
frappé quand j'avais vu l'extrême droite
néerlandaise percé en défendant les
homosexuels et les
LGBTQ tout simplement parce queil
s'agissait de taper sur des musulmans
qui eux étaient plus conservateurs hein
sur le plan des murs ce qui était pas du
tout la ligne politique du Front
national des années 70-80 qui était
antiféministe antihomosexuel
antiommuniste anti CGT anti tout d'une
certaine façon est très conservatrice il
cherche à déplacer ça mais en même temps
je partage ce qui a été dit par
plusieurs d'entre vous il reste quand
même des choses dans l'ADN du Front
National et du rassemblement national
qui vont peser hein c'est l'histoire du
père ça ça joue il y a pas que ça il y a
en effet le le Gude hein qui est ce
groupement d'étudiants d'extrême droite
dont Frédéric Chatillon faisait partie
qui sont quand même antisémites et et
très antiisraël et puis il y a des gens
qui peuvent être pro Israël et et pro
sionisme mais qui sont antisémites
prenez Victor Orban par exemple he qui
est un allié de de Marine Le Pen il est
fondamentalement antisémite son ennemi
numéro 1 c'est George Soros hein il
n'arrête pas de l'attaquer sur son
judaïsme hein bon alors est pro avoir
été financé par lui quandou aè il y a 30
ans on vit dans un monde très compliqué
pardon on sa c'est compliqué j'essaie de
suivre aussi audelà d'Orban l'extrême
droite américaine avec les évangélistes
qui étaient derrière Trump qui
soutiennent Israël en veut-tu en voilà
mais dont on oublie qu'ils sont
antisémites parce que il faut en effet
que les Juifs reviennent à Israël mais
ils ne seront sauvés que s'ils se
convertissent bien évidemment donc on a
derrière tout ça un ADN qui
malheureusement ou heureusement n'est
toujours làin Dina sur ce point le
rassemblement national entre intègre
l'arc républicain c'est ce que disait me
Habib je sais pas si aujourd'hui i l'arc
républicain a encore une réalité
politique depuis depuis plusieurs
semaines en tout cas c'est un mouvement
simplement peut-être pour remettre dans
le contexte politique de l'année passée
c'est un mouvement qui qui qui se
poursuit totalement dans la continuité
de de ce qui s'est fait à l'Assemblée
nationale aussi cette année à savoir des
députés insoumis extrêmement virulents
extrêmement bruyants et en face des
députés du rassemblement national
portant la cravate chaque jour dans une
démarche de notabilisation et avec
toujours cet objectif de montrer que eux
finalement sont plus dans l'arc
républicain que ne le sont les insoumis
et évidemment avec cet événement c'est
c'est du pain béni pour finalement
poursuivre cette stratégie encore
au-delà des murs de l'Assemblée
nationale parce que peut-être que ça
pouvait encore être circonscrit euh dans
le dans les murs du Parlement ben
maintenant ça les dépasse bien largement
la scène internationale est-elle aussi
chamboulée par les événements Proche
Orient les États-Unis ont réaffirmé leur
soutien à Israël dans cette épreuve la
Russie c'est quand elle contenté
d'appeler un retour au calme et en a
profité pour narguer un peu Washington
écoutez à cette heure nous nous devons
d'être absolument clair rien ne justifie
le terrorisme il n'y a pas d'excuse et
le type de terrorisme dont il a été fait
preuve ici est
inacceptable comme je l'ai dit hier mon
engagement pour la sécurité d'Israël et
pour la sécurité du peuple juif est
inébranlable les États-Unis soutiennent
Israël et nous allons poursuivre nos
efforts tout au long de la journée et
au-delà malheureusement nous constatons
une brusque aggravation de la situation
au moyenneorient je pense que beaucoup
de gens seraient d'accord avec moi pour
dire que c'est un exemple clair de
l'échec de la politique américaine au
Moyen-Orient Fabrice un monde divisé en
deux les États-Unis soutiennent Israël
la Russie est un peu plus sur le
reculoir sur le frein non mais c'est là
où c'est vraiment intéressant c'est que
effectivement quand on s'élève un peu et
qu'on on regarde la géopolitique c'est
on voit une recomposition d'alliance qui
est manifeste je veux dire là on voit
que la Russie et l'Iran il y a y a il y
a des objectifs communs on voit même la
proximité turque sur certains aspects on
voit les contradictions de l'autre côté
avec le la coalition que je vais appeler
faute de mieux occidentale qui appuie
plutôt
Israël les Britanniques qui envoient des
éléments de leur flotte à proximité pour
éventuellement soutenir les Américains
qui signalent qu'on ne peut pas avoir
d'ingérance d'un autre d'un côté les
démocraties de l'autre les autres c'est
aussi simple que ça c'est pas aussi
simple que ça parce qu'il y a des pays
intermédiaires que ce soit que ce soit
l'Azerbaïdjan que ce soit l'Afrique o il
y a il y a des des situations qui des
observateurs qui regardent ça avec
beaucoup de scepticisme et et beaucoup
de critique justement du du monde
occidental qui est toujours considéré
comme le responsable de tout au fond
même Lura
envahi par la Russie faut faut se
rappeler de ça et considéré comme en
fait l'agent l'élément de l'OTAN qui
voulait se développer donc quoi qui se
passe c'est toujours l'Occident qui a
tort donc c'est un peu cette coalition
des antioccidentaux qu'on voit un peu à
l'œuvre partout avec la Chine plus ou
moins proche Christophe là-dessus je
pense pas que les démocratie contre le
reste du monde hein puisque si vous
prenez l'Amérique latine le Brésil est
un grand État démocratique et évidemment
il n'est pas aligné ni sur l'Ukraine on
peut le regret mais c'est la réalité ni
sur l'affaire israélienne sur le sur
l'Occident non moi ce qui m'inquiète
vraiment c'est qu'il y a une espèce de
bloc occidental qui est en train de se
solidifier sur des questions comme
l'Ukraine et je pense que c'est juste
hein ça ne me pose évidemment aucun
problème sur la question Israël
palestinienne en partie sur la question
Chine hein puisque on voit bien que pour
les États-Unis c'est la Chine le nouveau
problème hein ça n'est plus l'Union
soviétique qui a disparu depuis 30 ans
mais c'est la Chine qui est qui est le
futur adversaire à cause de sa
croissance économique militaire et
cetera bon et je pense que ce qui est
problématique pour nous et on revient au
premier sujet de de de de la discussion
d'aujourd'hui c'est que la position
française et européenne d'une certaine
façon ne se différencie pas de la
position américaine sur toutes ces
sujets et je pense à la Chine mais
aujourd'hui à Israël et et à la question
palestinienne on a une voix qui devrait
être autonome qui était la VO différente
de la voie américaine c'est mais oui
prenez par exemple la position classique
de la France hein de Gaul à Chirac en
passant PARM Terran qui était l'idée
deux états hein donc les accords d'Oslo
tout ça inaudible plus personne n'en
parle or on sait bien
me non il l' rappelé en fin en fin
d'intervention et sans que ça n'it aucun
effet parce que reprenez
l'histoire quand Israël oui mais quand
Israël je finis là-dessus mais quand
Israël a été vraiment menacé à chaque
fois la sortie a été politique prenez
par exemple le guum Kipour 50 ans hein
bon il a fallu que s date etbin ancien
terroriste d'extrême droite par ailleurs
passe un accord pour que les choses se
règlent prenez la première antifada
quelle a été la sortie politique trè
parce que la sortie politique ça été les
accords d'Oslo bon si aujourd'hui dans
ces massacres épouvantables qui ont eu
lieu évidemment en Israël qui auront
lieu qui ont déjà lieu à Gaza si on veut
en sortir il faut un accord politique et
l'accord politique c'est la ligne
de on reparlera de ce
conflit pas un conflit si simple dans ce
jeu diplomatique c'est invité la
question des aides financières qui
partent d'Europe et qui vont vers les
Palestiniens certains pays dont
l'Allemagne ou la Suède ont annoncé la
ces a
écoutez notre annonce aujourd'hui est
que la Suède va suspendre l'aide au
développement la Palestine jusqu'à
nouvel
ordre nous allons également demander de
préparer un bilan de l'aide suédoise à
la
Palestine d'ici le 1er décembre
2023 la France qui a refusé de suspendre
cette je vous montrer ces chiffres le
budget de l'Union européenne consacré au
développement des territoires
palestiniens entre 2021 2024 et de 1,2
milliards d'euros Sophie pourquoi cette
question se pose aujourd'hui cette
question du du financement et du budget
des fonds àoués aux Palestiniens et bien
parce que c'est sans doute l'usage de
ces fonds qui est aussi en cause par le
protoétat du Hamas et évidemment à à en
Palestine on ne peut que le regretter
évidemment c'est c'est sans doute ce
qu'il y a dans dans dans l'esprit et de
de des responsables européens c'est de
savoir voilà quel est quel est l'usage
de ces fonds est-ce qu'il y a une
pression à à à exercer finalement pour
que
euh puisque nous sommes en pleine
offensive c'est compliqué de savoir ce
qui va se passer par la suite mais
évidemment que
euh la la tête militaire au moins du
Hamas va être décapitée ou au moins
écrasée et que là il va falloir faire
renaître quelque chose euh si euh par
euh drame il n'y a pas effectivement la
Constitution en Égypte d'un nouveau camp
avec des millions ou des centaines de
milliers question ce que vous c'est ce
financement est une question politique
c'est une question politique parce que
en gros le Hamas s'est servi de ses
moyens pour s'armer et pour frapper
Israël faut quand même dire les choses
et que par ailleurs les les gens du
Hamas sont quand même des grands
kleptocrates des gens qui vivent en
détournant une bonne partie des fonds
pour eux pour leur clientèle politique
et au détriment Gaza donc la question
c'est est-ce que notre aide est utilisée
de manière nette et on voit bien que le
rapprochement avec l'Iran euh est aussi
un élément qui est embarrassant pour
nous donc voilà la question de de l'aide
et son usage se pose voilà sachant que
si je peux me permettre on sait
qu'Israël a aussi aidé financièrement
les fonctionnaires du Hamas en 2018
d'ailleurs Emmanuel Macron en a fait
allusion quand il a rencontré les
responsables de parti jeudi cette
semaine euh il y a il y a là aussi une
responsabilité d'Israël elle-même non et
dans la répartition des fonds ceux qui
payent principalement le le le Hamas à
Gaza c'est le Qatar hein c'est pas
l'Union européenne l'Union européenne
inversé un certain volume le volume
d'IDE qui a rappelé non mais c surtout
sur, milliard de l'un c'est sur la
sjordanie principalement beaucoup plus
que sur gaz et c'est sur la population
palestinen en général bon avec des
choses qui sont euh d'un certain point
de vue groteses c'est qu'on a
reconstruit trois fois l'aérodrome de
Gaza à chaque fois détruit par les
on repar autour d'une autre émission
spéciale merci président l'arché c'est
la fin de cette émission merci à tous
les Quates d'avoir participer émission
particulière pas simple à réaliser mais
j'espère qu'on a pu apporter quelques
clés de compréhension à la situation
merci à vous derrière votre écran je
vous rappelle que vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission en replay sur notre
plateforme publicsena.fr on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine même jour même
heure et même endroit bye
bye
[Musique]
p